so in knowing that you think of the end
result in the story what prompted you to
want to do this story versus like a teen
vampire thriller okay well here's the
deal as a producer and actor as a
producer I'm looking to make a film that
audiences are going to enjoy as an actor
I need to make a film that I believe in
so I don't believe in vampire films or
you know teenagers running around
killing each other yeah I don't buy it
so as an actor I'm not going to be able
to express it so I need I need to find
something as a producer I need to put
forth the mainstream film that audiences
are going to like but as an actor I'm
going to have to pick a subject matter
which I believe in which is action drama
I believe in action and I believe in
drama so those are the film's I choose
to do and those that the film's I choose
to produce and make so in knowing that
would you say that filmmaking is
seventy-five percent business and
twenty-five percent creativity or I'm
putting words in your mouth yeah well
give me yet well you know um I think I I
think you got the I think you got the
statistics right but I'd go ahead and
flip him i'd say it's seventy-five
percent creativity and twenty-five
percent business because if you're just
in the business of making films then you
enter the world of like well let's just
crank out a really low budget film that
we know is going to make money like a
horror film and then you're you're
completely in the business of it because
your whole strategy is all about how
much money I'm going to make off this
film and then I can make my next one
then I can make my next one so then it
becomes 75% business and that's one way
to go I don't agree with that because
like I said being the actor as well as
the producer it has to be seventy-five
percent creativity because it's got to
be a story that that I feel I can walk
away from and be like yeah you know I
like that performance it's something
compelling it's a hell of a lot more
riskier than doing just a film based on
on numbers and figuring out a
civic demographic and knowing you can
make a profit off of it but but for me
it's it's a lot more rewarding so when I
go into a film it is solidly about 75%
creativity because the script has to be
exciting characters have to be exciting
the where we're shooting has to be
exciting everything has to be compelling
because if you're going to be the
driving force behind a film you have to
believe in it and you have to engross
yourself in and thrall yourself with it
and so it is highly creative at the same
time there's the part of you that has to
be very pragmatic and realistic on
expectations so when when I go into
shooting a film as a producer I I'm very
realistic about the outcome I'm not I'm
not going if the film thinking man this
is it I'm hitting a home run baby you
know I'm the next Vince Vaughn you know
this is my swingers no I'm not thinking
that at all I'm just thinking I gotta do
a good job if somehow people see it I
feel grateful if I actually make money
off of it it's it's a plus you know it's
definitely a plus but I go in there with
very realistic expectations like okay
you know you're going against a lot of
great people and the probability of you
succeeding is pretty close to 20 so
you've got to go in there with that sort
of solemn attitude and and for me for me
I it's got to be very creative but yeah
it'd be cool to be more business-minded
but but if I was just a producer I
probably could do that but since I'm
acting in the film's you just can't do
it
you